요즘 중국을 둘러싼 분위기를 보면 좀 이상합니다.
사람들은 다 중국이 위험하다고 말합니다.
중국산을 견제해야 한다, 공급망을 줄여야 한다,
너무 의존하면 안 된다, 이런 말을 계속하죠.
그런데 현실은 어떻습니까?
전기차도 중국산이 더 많이 보이고,
배터리도 중국 기준이 크고, 태양강은
사실 중국을 빼고는 설명이 잘 안 됩니다.
말로는 멀리하자고 하는데 실제로는 점점 더 많이 쓰고 있습니다.
바로 이 이상한 장면이 지금 세계 경제의 핵심입니다.
그리고 많은 분들이 여기서 한 가지 착각을 합니다.
그냥 중국 물건이 싸니까 잘 팔리는 거 아니야?
이 정도로 생각하는 경우가 꽤 많습니다.
그런데 지금 벌어지는 일은 그 정도로 단순하지 않습니다.
예전에 중국 쇼크는 값싼 생활용품의 홍수였습니다.
옷, 신발, 가구, 장난감 같은 것들이 싸게 쏟아져 들어오던 시기였죠.
그런데 지금은 다릅니다.
이번에는 전기차, 배터리, 태양강,
조선, 기계 같은 훨씬 더 중요하고 훨씬 더 복잡한 산업에서
중국이 밀고 들어오고 있습니다.
그러니까 예전에는 마트 선반이 바뀌는 정도의 이야기였다면
지금은 공장 구조 자체가 바뀌는 이야기인 겁니다.
이걸 가장 잘 보여주는 숫자가 바로 무역 흑자입니다.
중국은 2025년에 상품 무역 흑자가 1조 1890억 달러까지 올라갔습니다.
사상 최대였죠.
쉽게 말하면 중국은 세계에 파는 건 엄청나게 많은데
밖에서 사오는 건 그만큼 늘지 않고 있다는 뜻입니다.
게다가 이건 한두 달 반짝이 아니라
2025년에 월간 무역 흑자가 1000억 달러를 넘는 달이
7번이나 나왔을 정도로 강한 흐름이었습니다.
이게 왜 중요하냐면 흑자가 크다는 건
단순히 장사를 잘했다는 말로 끝나지 않기 때문입니다.
그건 곧 중국이 세계 시장의 물건을 엄청나게 밀어넣고 있다는 뜻이고
다른 나라 입장에선 자국 기업들이 그만큼 더 직접적으로
수출을 받는다는 뜻입니다.
실제로 2025년에 중국의 대미 수출은 줄었는데도
아세안 수출은 13.4%
EU 수출은 8.4%
아프리카 수출은 25.8% 늘었습니다.
미국이 막는다고 끝나는 구조가 아니라
다른 시장으로 우회하고 넓혀가는 구조라는 뜻입니다.
그런데 더 중요한 건 따로 있습니다.
이 장면은 중국이 너무 성장 동력이 뛰어나서 생긴 결과가 아니라는 겁니다.
겉으로 보면 중국 경제는 강해 보입니다.
2026년에 중국이 중국 경제에 강해졌다.
2027년 1분기 성장률은 5.0%
분기 성장률은 1.3%였습니다.
표면상으로는 버틴다가 아니라 생각보다 괜찮다는 숫자죠.
그런데 안을 들여다보면 그림이 달라집니다.
사물 소매 판매 증가율은 1.7%에 그쳤고
1분기 고정자산 투자도 1.7% 증가에 그쳤습니다.
부동산 투자는 같은 기간 11.2% 감소했습니다.
지금 공장을 돌리면서 수출로 버티고 있는데
내수는 생각보다 약하다는 뜻입니다.
그래서 지금의 무역 억자는 단순한 성적표가 아니라
중국 내부 문제와 세계 시장이 만나는 지점이라고 보는 게 더 맞습니다.
IMF도 최근 중국이 수출 의존을 줄이고 내수를 더 키워야 한다는 경고를 하고 있죠.
이제 여기서 질문이 하나 더 생깁니다.
도대체 뭐가 그렇게 무서운가?
중국이 물건 좀 많이 파는 게 왜 세계 경제 충격이 되는 거냐 이거죠.
이유는 아주 단순합니다.
이번에는 품목이 다르기 때문입니다.
장난감이랑 전기차는 다릅니다.
신발이랑 배터리는 다릅니다.
가구랑 대기차는 다릅니다.
태양광은 다릅니다.
이런 산업들은 하나만 팔고 끝나는 산업이 아닙니다.
예를 들어서 전기차를 보겠습니다.
중국은 2025년에 전기차를 260만 대 수출했습니다.
금액으로는 696억 달러 전년보다 43% 증가했습니다.
그리고 이 전기차가 들어간 나라와 지역이 150곳이 넘습니다.
상위 수입국도 벨기에, 영국, 아랍에미리트처럼 특정 지역에만 몰려 있지 않습니다.
그러니까 이건 유럽 일부가 중국 차를
조금씩 사야 한다고 생각합니다.
4분다 수준이 아니라 이미 여러 대륙으로 퍼지는 흐름입니다.
여기서 더 중요한 숫자가 하나 있습니다.
중국산 EV에 10억 달러 이상을 쓴 나라가 2025년에 22개국이었습니다.
이 말은 중국 전기차가 이제 시험 단계가 아니라
여러 나라에서 본격적인 시장 점유 경쟁 단계로 들어갔다는 뜻입니다.
그러니까 중국은 차만 파는 게 아니라
중국식 전기와 생태계 전체를 같이 밀어놓고 있다는 것에 가깝습니다.
차가 들어가면 배터리가 따라가고,
충전 인프라가 따라가고, 전력 장비가 따라갑니다.
배터리는 더 중요합니다.
차는 눈에 보이니까 다들 자동차 이야기를 많이 하는데
진짜 힘은 배터리에 있습니다.
배터리를 누가 쥐고 있느냐에 따라
전기차도, 에너지 저장 장치도, 전력망 전환도 다 영향을 받습니다.
중국의 배터리 수출은 2025년에 7,700억 위안,
우리 돈으로 보면 엄청난 규모였고,
2022년보다 50% 늘었습니다.
그리고 2024년 기준으로 EU가 수입한 리튬,
리튬이온 배터리의 86%,
미국이 수입한 리튬이온 배터리의 70%가 중국산이었습니다.
그러니 다들 중국을 견제한다고 말하면서도
당장 끊지는 못하는 겁니다.
실제로 미국도 배터리 저장장치 설치가
2025년에 58기가와트시로 30% 증가했고,
2026년에도 60기가와트시가 더 들어설 것으로 보이는데,
2021년부터 2025년 초까지 미국 배터리 수입의 절반은 중국산이었습니다.
말로는 줄이자고 해도, 현실은 중국산입니다.
중국산은 중국산이 아니라 중국산이 아니라 중국산입니다.
태양광은 더 극단적입니다.
이건 거의 뭐 중국을 빼고 그림이 안 그려질 정도입니다.
2024년 기준으로 중국은 전세계 태양광 공급망에서
폴리실리콘 93.2%, 웨이퍼 96.6%,
쉘 92.3%, 모듈 86.4%를 차지했습니다.
핵심 단계 대부분을 사실상 중국이 장악하고 있다는 뜻입니다.
게다가 생산 능력은 세계 수요보다 훨씬 큽니다.
중국 태양광 공급망은 중국산이 장악하고 있다는 뜻입니다.
게다가 생산 능력은 세계 수요보다 훨씬 큽니다. 중국 태양광 공급망은 중국산이 장악하고 있다는 뜻입니다.
중국 태양광 공급망은 중국산이 장악하고다는 뜻입니다.
태양광 공장들의 생산 능력은 2025년
세계 수요의 거의 2배 수준으로 추정됐고
전세계 전체 태양광 제조 능력도
실제 설치량의 2배가 넘는 수준으로 평가됐습니다.
지금 중국은 시장이 100을 원하면
공장은 200 이상을 만들 수 있는 상태라는 겁니다.
이렇게 되면 어떤 일이 벌어질까요?
가격이 무너지겠죠.
소비자 입장에서는 좋습니다.
싸게 살 수 있으니까요.
전력망 입장에서도 좋습니다.
보급 속도를 빨리 올릴 수 있으니까요.
그런데
다른 나라 기업 입장에서는 지옥입니다.
이 가격을 버티기가 너무 어렵다는 겁니다.
같이 경쟁하다가 밀려날 수밖에 없는 구조입니다.
그래서 세계가 중국을 동시에 원하고 동시에 두려워하는 겁니다.
싸고 좋은 제품은 필요합니다.
하지만 그걸 받아들이는 순간 자국 산업이 흔들립니다.
바로 이 딜레마가 지금 핵심입니다.
여기서 유럽이 왜 민감하게 반응하는지도 이해할 수 있습니다.
중국 제품이 많이 들어온다는 건 그냥 수입이 늘었다는 뜻이 아닙니다.
유럽 제조업이 직접 압박을 받는다는 뜻입니다.
그리고 미국이 관세로 문을 닫아도 중국은 멈추지 않습니다.
아세안으로 가고 아프리카로 가고 유럽으로 가고 중남미로 갑니다.
문 하나 닫히면 다른 문으로 돌아갑니다.
그래서 이건 미국과 중국만의 싸움이 아니라
중국의 거대한 생산 능력이 세계 전체를 눌러오는 장면에 더 가깝습니다.
그럼 세계는 어떻게 하고 있을까요?
깔끔한 답이 아직도 없습니다.
미국도 유럽도 완전히 중국을 끊지는 못합니다.
그렇다고 그냥 다 받아들이기도 어렵습니다.
그래서 지금 대부분의 나라가 선택하는 방식은 완전히 막지도 않고 완전히 열지도 않습니다.
어떤 건 막고 어떤 건 받아들이고 받아들이더라도 조건을 붙입니다.
현지에서 생산해라. 고용을 우리나라에서 만들어라. 부품도 여기서 써라.
이런 식으로 말이죠.
한마디로 세계는 지금 중국을 배제하는 방법보다
중국을 관리하는 방법을 찾고 있는 쪽에 가깝습니다.
이제 우리 이야기로 돌아와 보겠습니다.
많은 분들이 이걸 중국과 미국의 문제처럼 듣습니다.
그런데 한국은 절대 구경꾼이 아닙니다.
오히려 한가운데 서 있습니다.
전기차, 배터리, 조선, 철강, 화합, 기계
우리가 먹고 사는 핵심 산업 대부분이 여기에 걸쳐 있습니다.
그래서 한국의 고민도 똑같습니다.
중국산을 막으면 비용이 오릅니다.
받아들이면 경쟁이 더 거세집니다.
빨리 가고 싶으면 중국이 유리하고
산업을 지키고 싶으면 대가를 치러야 합니다.
그러니까 이 문제를 중국이 싫다 좋다 수준으로 보면
항상 핵심을 놓치게 됩니다.
진짜 중요한 건 어디서 싸울지, 우리가 어디에 협력할지,
어디를 끝까지 지켜낼지를 구체적으로 정하는 겁니다.
정리해 보겠습니다.
중국의 기록적 무효 극자가 세계경제에 주는 충격의 본질은
중국이 단순히 물건을 많이 판다는 데 있지 않습니다.
중국이 안에서는 충분히 소비하지 못하면서
밖으로는 더 중요하고 더 복잡한 제품을
더 싸게, 더 많이 내보내고 있다는 데 있습니다.
이건 더 이상 분위기나 느낌의 문제가 아니라
산업 지형이 실제로 바뀌고 있다는 신호입니다.
과거의 중국 쇼크가 생활용품 시장을 바꿨다면
지금의 중국 쇼크 2.0은 공장과 전력망,
자동차 시장과 산업 정책 자체를 바꾸고 있습니다.
그래서 이건 단순한 중국 뉴스가 아닙니다.
앞으로 세계 제조업 질서가 어떻게 다시 짜일지를 보여주는 이야기입니다.
그리고 그 한가운데에 지금 한국도 함께 서 있습니다.
여러분들의 생각은 어떠신가요?
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.